there's no doubt Eleanor Williams was a
troubled teenager but could she also
have been the victim of horrific abuse
at the hands of a gang of alleged sex
traffickers or did she do this to
herself
that was the question facing the jury at
Preston Crown Court
still got a scar on her throat it's
right across there
on top of that she's had a breasts Corp
she's got two marks across there Aria's
being caught her fingers being caught
she's got rats curved across her stomach
Elena's mother Alison says as a teenager
her daughter became withdrawn and in
early 2019 aged 18 she suddenly left
home moving to this block of flats in
Barrow in finesse in Cumbria over seven
months Alison reported her daughter
missing 32 times
she was going missing for days on end I
was driving around where she lived and I
noticed that a light was on in a flat so
I went and knocked on the door and she
opened the door and her face was oh she
had two black eyes it was so swole and I
hardly recognized her and she had a cut
across her neck she was just black and
blue all over staff at the pub where
Miss Williams worked also noticed the
injuries and thought she was being
bullied one day she came in with um a
particularly bad set of black eyes
and I said to her look just
just tell me what's going on I'll be
able to help you there are only kids she
didn't say anything for about two
minutes
and then she said it wouldn't stop and
they weren't children they were they
were grown men
and it wouldn't stop because they were
using her to get profit police in Barrow
began an investigation finding evidence
on her phone that suggested she was
being sexually exploited and trafficked
by a group of men across the north of
England at times Eleanor Williams
appeared to be a reluctant witness but
over the course of their investigation
police began to suspect that she was
lying about the abuse and arrested her
then one evening in May 2020 while on
bail she went missing again she was
found badly injured in this field near
her family home she made the decision to
go public with her allegations posting
them on Facebook she was taken into
custody within minutes of putting the
post up but the reaction to it was
explosive
it was a Shockwave really it was just
right through the town there were these
huge rallies
um which you know loads of people
attended to people beeping homes and
things like that
people thought you know how could this
have happened and you know not I think
not too long after that it was you know
it was police outside takeaways it was
smash Windows it was people being abused
on social media
Miss Williams didn't name anyone in her
post it became public knowledge and
Barrow one of the men she'd accused was
a local businessman who denied her
allegations
hi hello hi Jason what was the impact on
your family what kind of threats were
you what pledge we had we had messages
like the people are going to rape my
wife in front of me from Islam from
Islam before yeah
to just general hate people wish he'd be
dead Mr Ramsey says his children were
also threatened did you say that they
had fire distinguishers baseball bats
next to the beds for the safety because
we had threats people were going to burn
us burn the shops down burn us down
we owned these properties the next Doors
by it as well rental properties in town
smashed you know it was that right it's
not the type of persecution that goes on
today and they turned on you and the
third one and do you think that they
they the the majority of the Town
thought that you were a sex offender I I
think yes I would say yes they did at
Preston Crown court evidence emerged
Eleanor Williams appeared to have fakes
messages and letters to herself and she
admitted staying in a hotel in Blackpool
all at a time when she'd said she'd been
trafficked the prosecution argued that
what Ellie Williams says happened here
in Baron finesse is a complete fantasy
and not only that but she went to Great
Lengths to make people believe that it
was true even buying a hammer to inflict
those wounds upon herself but in court
Ellie Williams said I didn't buy a
hammer to hurt myself I'm not a
psychopath
the jury at Preston Crown Court found
that Eleanor Williams lied and was
guilty of perverting the course of
justice but what's harder to understand
is why she did it Jason Farrell Sky News